over the sentence me and Maggie started
to grow a distance it was like she was
just somebody else that was there it
really sunk in and I was on my own
one morning I had received some photos
from home they was brought in by an
officer
are you pregnant English girl oh she
added me the envelope she said to me we
don't deserve it tell you have a home
that alone two one at you're carrying no
everyone around me hey it means that a
situation that I'd put a baby and she
was the only one that was actually brave
enough to come out and say something the
next few months in prison passed quickly
living with the same routine day in and
day out there I always used to talk to
him told him that he was going to be a
special little boy I would be allowed to
keep him with me for three months after
the three months was up if one of my
family members couldn't come to collect
the baby he would go into the care of
their government
during me being pregnant I received a
phone call from my mom
mark had gone off with somebody else to
me he wasn't waiting for me anymore no
no no no I just broke that I cannot do
this I was in that situation and
carrying his child and he's just gone
and left me like that it was like I was
carrying this part of mark that wasn't
one it wasn't loved and sort of made me
resent the baby as well I was thinking
of asking my mom to come over basically
take him straight from birth couple of
days after I woke up and remembered the
baby not moving throughout the night I
was taken to the hospital
when the doctor revealed that I was
already halfway through my labor I was
rushed on to the maternity ward not
having a familiar person with me when I
went to have the baby really kicked in I
was on my own
keep breathing
the water from the prison arrived
although it was her I was imagining my
mom being there and giving me the
support and go ahead that I needed I
didn't believe that I would have the
strength to pour fruit
when I first seed a baby the love and
warmth I felt for him just filled my
heart straightaway